مصطفى الكستوني كان طفلا ترعرع في ظل
الاحتلال وعاش مجزره المخيم قبل احدى
وعشرين سنه كبيره ليصبح مقاوما
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم قوات الاحتلال تقتحم
جنين وتغتال احد قاده كتائب شهداء الاقصى
ليرتفع عدد الفلسطينيين الذين استشهدوا
منذ بدايه العام الى
228 كتيبه جنين قالت ان مقاتليها اشتبكوا
مع القوات التي تسللت الى المدينه في حين
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي اصابه اثنين من
جنوده في الضفه الغربيه في اول زياره
رسميه له للسعوديه منذ استئناف العلاقات
وزير الخارجيه الايراني يقول ان العلاقات
بين البلدين تسير في الاتجاه الصحيح وان
هناك امكانيه للعمل على حل الملفات
العالقه في الاقليم ونظيره السعودي يؤكد
حرص المملكه على تفعيل الاتفاقات السابقه
بين البلدين لا سيب الامنيه
قاده جيوش دول غرب افريقيا يضعون خطه
نهائيه لتدخل عسكري محتمل في النيجر
ويشددون على استعاده النظام الدستوري هناك
في اي وسيله في وقت اعلنت فيه الولايات
المتحده ارسال سفيرتها الى النيامي دون
تقديم اوراق اعتمادها للسلطات العسكريه
الانجليزيه
على اشبيليه الاسباني بركلات الترجيح
وبذلك يدخل المدرب الاسباني
تاريخ كاس السوبر بعدما بات المدرب الاكثر
فوزا بها مشاركه مع الايطاليه
الى اللقاء